welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google Cloud my name is lack and
I'm going to be talking today about
public datasets on Google cloud
we have Googlers available on standby to
answer questions so please ask questions
on the platform so when we're talking
about public datasets we of course start
with what's available what what kind of
public datasets are there there are
essentially three different types of
public data on Google cloud the first of
them are the datasets that are on Google
bigquery the query is of course the data
warehouse in Google Cloud it's a good
place to store structured data sets
because you can query them using
standard sequel you get querying up to
one terabyte per month for no charge and
to just show you the kinds of things
that are available I'll go to this
website console the cloud at google.com
slash marketplace so I'll go into the
marketplace and you can scroll down and
you see that there are datasets
available but instead of going ahead and
clicking on these datasets I could
basically go ahead and say let me go
ahead and find New York City 3 1 1 data
so 3 1 1 in New York City is where New
Yorkers call in with complaints
municipal complaints so we can go there
click on this data set and in addition
to viewing the data set there are a
couple of example queries available so
let's go ahead and this sounds very
interesting which New York boroughs have
the most number of parties if you decide
to move to New York where do you want to
go live so let's go ahead and run this
query and what I'll do is I will go
ahead wait for the query to load and
this is the classic UI but I love the
new UI in bigquery so let me go ahead
and switch to the new UI so that is the
query and let me go ahead and run the
query and there we go the query
basically says no matter of seconds that
the borough is you know in Brooklyn we
had 110,000
or more parties and and so on right and
this is the different party days one
being Sunday and seven being Saturday
and as you would expect most of the
parties are on Saturdays and Sundays
although Manhattan seems to have some
parties on Fridays as well so where are
the really loud parties well one thing
that we did was we just went ahead and
did the query but let's go ahead and do
something cooler let's go ahead and
explore this data in data studio so what
this is doing is that it's going ahead
and running this query for us and I will
change right now this is basically based
on the record count so let me go ahead
and change the metric to be the number
of parties and instead of doing the sum
let me choose the max and let's change
this to be a bar chart and there we go
Brooklyn has the most number of parties
followed by Manhattan followed by Queens
and we saw how easy it was to go from a
data set to do a query and to go ahead
and display it using data studio so what
was different about this and it's kind
of good to step back and say okay what
exactly was different so sure I showed
you going to a website running a sequel
query and then going into another
website and visualizing the data all in
one workflow so great but the key thing
that's different here is that the data
didn't actually move anywhere that data
was there in bigquery it was there on
the Google cloud and what we did was
that we brought a whole bunch of compute
to this data so if you were to go to
this data set so let's go ahead and view
the data set and let's see there is a
3-1-1 service requests and look at the
details of this data set that was eight
almost nine gigs of data that we queried
in a matter of seconds how is that
possible the only reason it's possible
was because we threw thousands of
machines on this one sequel query to
execute it and there is no way that this
data was present on those compute nodes
instead just like these birds flocking
over a/c we brought a bunch of machines
to go ahead and process the data in a
distributed form and give us the answer
back so if you were to think of what the
old world was in terms of data analysis
the old world was to go ahead and
download data to your laptop analyze the
data and then distribute the results but
that old world doesn't really work
anymore and the reason it doesn't work
is that the kind of data sets that we
are now dealing with are much much much
larger if you take an industrial use
case you're probably producing anywhere
from half a terabyte to four terabytes
per machine per year or healthcare a
typical Hospital of more than a terabyte
per month or transportation you have
about two gigs of data a year and if
you're in retail you may be collecting
up to four gigs of data per day per
product line this is a lot of data and
when you think of that kind of data
this old workflow of where you start
with downloading data it doesn't work
anymore because data doesn't fit the
other thing that happens is that when
you want to do your processing there is
a lot more compute power available on
the cloud and especially when it gets
into things like machine learning what's
shown here is a tensor processing unit a
TPU a custom ASIC for machine learning
and if you want to do machine learning
on large datasets and do them in a fast
way you need to be able to access
hardware like this and at that point be
thinking of analyzing data on your
laptop it doesn't really work because
you need lots of compute to be able to
do your analysis to do especially your
machine learning on data sets that's
large and the third aspect of this is
that in the old world you would
distribute reports it was okay if you
just give somebody a PDF but these days
everyone is used to interactive reports
they want to be able to do what I just
did
data studio or what you do when you when
somebody sends you a map they don't send
you a PDF of a map they send your Google
map that you can then go ahead and
interact with and that's true of charts
that's true of documents people are used
to interactive reports and so when you
distribute the results of your data
analysis they need to be interactive and
so the old world where you download the
data analyze the data on your laptop and
then email your results as a PDF those
don't work anymore so the new world is a
world in which you need to analyze share
your data and do your reports and so
what I just did in that demo of finding
the the like the boroughs in New York
with a most number of parties that
Illustrated this new world this new
world where the data stays in place and
you bring your analysis to it and that
is what public data sets on Google Cloud
or about it's about the data staying in
place and being able to do massive
amounts of compute on the data and to be
able to provide the results of that
analysis in a form that your end users
can still play around with can interact
with can query it themselves as well so
the whole idea here is that we started
with a data set that we started with a
data set and having gotten the data set
we went ahead and clicked on the query
and then we ran the query and then we
clicked on exploring data studio and
then I wasn't that interactive report
and I was able to go ahead and change
the way I displayed the data and I did
the data and all of this as possible and
with data studio I can share these
things and it's all possible because
it's all on the cloud and the data
remains in place I mean there's no way
you can think of moving nine gigs of
data around every time you want to do
analysis like this the data needs to
stay in place and you need to bring
compute to the data but this is not just
about analysis so what I just showed you
with parties in New York was about
analysis but for sudden you coul think
machine learning and so even in bigquery
right with our datasets we can actually
train a machine learning model and this
time I'll pick a dataset also from New
York on to predict a taxi fare so given
the pickup location and the drop-off
location I would like to basically
figure out what would the taxi cost and
in order to do that I will go back and
look at historical data of all kinds of
taxi trips and what was the actual
amount paid by passengers taking those
taxi trips and this will allow me to
demonstrate bigquery ml and also
bigquery GIS because it's a spatial data
set people get picked up at specific
locations dropped off at specific
locations and rather than do it from the
user interface bigquery user interface
this time I'll do it from a Python
notebook and I'll also show you another
cool tool called a geo map or G of s so
going down here so this is a github
repository that contains a taxi fare
model so this is a Python notebook I
just loaded it into data lab which is a
Python notebook environment I can go
ahead and in data lab I can click on a
cell and I can run the cell and this
allows me to run it and let's see so we
can go down here you do the Python
imports and here now is my bigquery
query so the key part of this query is
that I'm selecting some number of rows
from a table of New York City Taxi trips
so I can go ahead and run that and then
I can say go ahead and execute this
query and I get a thousand of them and I
can look at the top few records and
there is my trip start head and so on
and so we can go ahead and you know look
at the description of those things but
that is at this point just still data
and
so let's look at this line this is the
line that does the machine learning so
take your query that pulls in records
and in this case I'm pulling records
that contain the hour of the day the
pickup longitude the pickup latitude the
drop of longitude the drop of latitude
all of which come from the data and the
total fare that was paid and that also
comes from the data the total fare being
the actual fare amount plus any tolls
etc so those are the columns and I say
please go ahead and create a machine
learning model to predict the taxi fare
using a linear regression model and the
rest of these things are optional so we
can do that and at this point we can go
ahead and say run this query for me I
don't want to overwrite the query I
already have so I'll call this demos 2
and I'll go ahead and say I've run the
query oh I need to run this tell and
then run the query and we can then go
ahead and execute the query and this
takes about five to ten minutes so I'll
let that execute and I'll assume that
it's already done and I'll just move on
to what you would get at the end of it
so after that what you will get is that
in bigquery there will be a model that's
created that is capable of doing this
prediction and notice that all that we
really did was that we took a normal
bigquery query that the standard sequel
and added three lines go ahead and
create the model with this particular
algorithm to predict this column based
on all these other columns and at that
point we also get back the training loss
as the error decreases as the model
trains we can evaluate it on another
independent data set so this is just
another bigquery query where I'm doing a
select of an M from an ml that evaluate
and then I can go ahead and look at the
errors and the errors turn out to be
about six dollars on average and then we
can also go ahead and evaluate it based
on okay so we have six dollars an
average error
does the arrow change depending on where
people were picked up or where people
were dropped off and so what I can do
is that I can go ahead and select the
total fare I can go ahead and find the
error and group it by dollars group it
by the amount of fare and if I did that
I would find that the errors are really
small when the fare is around eleven
dollars and it increases quadratically
on each side so it basically on very
expensive trips and very cheap trips the
errors are very high and so this says
well we need to do something else so
what I'll do is I'll go ahead and add
the st underscore Geographic point which
is a spatial query in bigquery so this
allows me to basically treat a pickup
longitude and pick up latitude not as
two independent points but as one point
a pickup point and having gotten that
pickup point
then I will go ahead and compute the
distance st underscore distance between
the pick-up and drop-off point and I'll
use that as one of my training variables
so even though this is not present in
the original data I'm now using some
geospatial functions to go ahead and
create a new feature and when I do that
long story short my errors become very
flat across all of these dollar ranges
so I'm actually learning to predict much
better and then let's go ahead and
visualize it and let's now let's look at
how these errors change based on
location so what I'm doing to do is that
I'm gonna basically take this query
which what it does is that it groups
these things by drop off grid point and
I'll go to the bigquery G of this and
put my project ID in there and say that
I want to run that query
okay and run that query
okay so there it is so see the results
and I'll change it to the drop of grid
point and I see my results here let me
go ahead and change the style and change
the fill color to be data-driven and
make it a linear interval and let's go
ahead and do the range of that color and
maybe from 0 to 20 and the field could
be the mean absolute error and let's go
ahead and do that and you see that the
colors are different but at this point
my original data
the resolution is actually pretty small
because I did resolution of 0.1 degrees
let me change that to 0.01 degrees so
now I get a lot more points I can go
back to my style and there we go and as
you can see let me let me change the
color a little bit okay cool so you can
see that the errors are low in Manhattan
and as the as you go further and further
away into Brooklyn etc the errors
increase and this is a kind of
visualization that we did relatively
quickly on the map so let's move back
here okay so cool that was great I just
trained it trained a model machine
learning model based on a public data
set the New York City Taxi Cab data set
to predict taxi fare so I said there's
different way types of public data sets
available on Google cloud I spend about
15 minutes sidetracked on bigquery so
let's now talk about what else is
available so we started talking about
three types of public data the second
type of public data that's available on
Google cloud is the Google genomics data
so genomics data consists of two parts
you have some datasets in bigquery these
are things like variance etc you have
another data set on cloud storage these
are like the BAM VCF files and so on and
there is a link if you want to learn
more but one of the things that you
doom is that you could actually go ahead
and use bigquery you could use bigquery
to go ahead and run a query like this
where you are joining against your own
table against a thousand genome data set
for example to figure out something
about the variance and I won't embarrass
myself by talking too much more about
genomics because I don't know too much
about it but there is a data set where
you can actually compare a particular
genome that you have against against one
of the public genomes the third type of
public data set that you have are
geospatial datasets geospatial datasets
like Landsat images or NEXRAD images
these are images that are present on
Google Cloud storage so not in bigquery
any verb on Google Cloud storage in some
cases the metadata what files are
available what times are available etc
are present in bigquery but the actual
data themselves the raster data is on
cloud storage and also we have of course
the Earth engine data sets which is
another huge amount of geospatial data
sets that that are available for use as
well so what is the point of this so I
said initially that public data sets are
about bringing computer to the data and
I showed that with the case of bigquery
where we had these large data sets and
we were able to do sequel queries on
that data set well when you look at
geospatial data sets it's exactly the
same way you have your public data sets
in cloud storage and you will be able to
process them with the data in place but
this time the processing typically
happens in cloud dataflow cloud dataflow
is an execution environment for Apache
beam pipelines and you can write a Paget
beam code either in Python or in Java so
you have two two SDKs two API so you use
you write your code and in Apache beam
Python or Python or Java and you run it
in cloud dataflow so it's loosely like
how do you write standard C
and you run it in bigquery so you you do
Apache beam and you run it in data flow
and as an example let me show you an
example in the news today in the US with
Florence just having been here so let's
let's look at an earlier hurricane
hurricane maria and i'll basically show
you how to process weather data in real
time in bigquery and in data flow so the
idea here so so here's a blog post and
i'll just walk through it a little bit
so there is a big query public data set
that consists of NOAA hurricanes all of
the hurricanes all over the world
basically you can go ahead and get the
latitudes along it here's a time that
that data where and in this case i'm
saying find me a hurricane whose name
has maria in it and from 2017 and order
it by iso time so what i'm gonna now get
is the full path of the hurricane so i
have the latitude and longitude that
Maria was in and the time at which that
it hurricane was at that location and
how far away from landfall was that
particular hurricane so from this time
step right what I'm going to then do is
and I'm gonna go ahead and look inside
the Google cloud public data set I can
go I said find out my satellite data for
that particular year for that particular
date and we can go ahead and pull up the
appropriate satellite data so we can go
ahead go to this public bucket so this
is a public bucket and this is where the
public dataset comes in and we can pull
up that particular timestamp and having
done that this is in a format called
netcdf and you can you have Python coded
Java libraries to be able to read it so
in this case I'm using the the the
Python library to read netcdf files and
I'm reading those and I'm plotting them
using math map plot like so you can
basically go from bigquery figure out
what what
that you want to access access the data
using Python it's just a data in cloud
storage and you can do all of the kinds
of things that you would normally do
with satellite data what gets
interesting though is if you want to
process large amounts of data all at
once and so that's what the next part of
this is showing so this is now an Apache
beam pipeline where I'm saying go ahead
and run this hurricane query and for
every row of the hurricane query find me
all of the ghost files the satellite
data files at this particular latitude
and at this particular longitude and
convert them into JPEG so at that point
I will then get on data flow an auto
scaling pipeline that that processes in
this case it's getting all of the
hurricanes everywhere and then basically
creating a separate loop for every one
of the hurricanes a kind of distributed
processing that allows you to process
terabytes of data at scale over hundreds
of machines if you need to and this is
the plot for example of Hurricane Maria
and the other thing you can do is that
you can also listen to pop sub which is
a real-time data filter every time a new
satellite image hits cloud storage we
publish an event onto pub/sub so you can
go into pub/sub and you can listen for
that pop sub message and you can do some
processing so what I'm doing here is I'm
doing very simple processing I'm
basically going head and cropping out a
part of the image that corresponds to
Seattle and I'm basically saying here's
the satellite image over Seattle at this
current point in time but as with the
hurricane data you can do this for every
city in the US you can do it for
different areas you can create loops you
can do all of those kinds of things and
the cool thing is you can do them all in
real time so with that right I'll
basically leave you with some resources
first of all shameless plug for my book
if you're interested in doing data
analysis data science machine learning
on Google Plus
there is a there's over I live work data
science and Google platform written by
yours truly the second thing is that we
have a number of courses on Coursera and
if you're watching this webinar go to
Coursera coursera.org slash next
extended and you will get one month of
courses free on the platform so please
take advantage of it and finally if you
go to quick clubs there's a variety of
labs including many of the things that
are demonstrated are as labs that you
can try out yourself and that's a wrap
stay tuned for live Q&A we'll be back in
about a minute
welcome back so I'm taking questions
right now so if you have more questions
please add them to the platform so first
question how often are these public
datasets updated to reflect new data
great question there are some datasets
for example the satellite data that I
just showed you that satellite data
streams into into the cloud cloud and so
we actually have new data every you know
every time there's a new image that's
downloaded from the satellite so if
you're taking over full disk it's every
15 minutes but lots of times you have
new data every minute so it is it's near
real-time for cases like Landsat data
for cases like Sentinel for cases like
the ghost data for the bigquery data
sets also if you're taking thinking for
example the City Bikes data and all the
goes temperature or the G sort
temperature data the weather data all of
those kinds of things as and when new
data is available from the public data
set provider that data is is reflected
on Google cloud as well so the answer to
how often are these public Edison's
updated it is like we try to keep them
as up-to-date as we can some data sets
like the zip codes data set we might
update like once a year the utility data
sets but for the most part no as a rule
of thumb the public data sets are as
up-to-date as the provider of the public
data sets allows us to be second
question how do you decide which data
sets to feature on your public data sets
program this is where you can help if
you have suggestions on what data sets
we should be featuring data sets that
you would find useful please do let us
know and remember that even though I
talked about public data sets on Google
cloud there is a lot of public data
available out there there's data on
earth engine there's data on
iago and for to some extent our goal
with the Google cloud public data sets
program is to focus on datasets where
it's large enough or it's useful enough
that it's going so number one it's very
large so you need to bring compute to
the data so we want to basically feature
it to make it easier for folks the
second reason is that it's a very useful
data set like the zip code data set it's
not very large but it is an extremely
useful data set so we will have we will
have it as a utility data set so people
don't have to each per each individual
company doesn't have to do that so it's
a so we either do it as a public good or
we do it as because it's a very large
computing even though like genomics data
is not very widely used but it's very
useful and it's very large so we tend to
feature it and so how the way we decide
is please let us know and if your if
you're a provider of data and you would
like your data to be featured on Google
cloud also do contact us there's two
ways to do it we can do the public data
set but we can also do the Google cloud
marketplace which allows you to monetize
your data set third question you sure
the number of links how can I get a copy
of your slides so that I can visit those
websites good point if you stick around
in the Q&A we will post a link there - -
to my presentation so that you can
actually get access and then you can go
to those that link and then all of the
other links are available so feel free
to explore my deck has lots and lots of
links and each of them is a it's a great
set of things to go ahead and explore so
strongly encourage you to do that fourth
question that's a cool one bigquery
machine learning seems very cool when
should I use bigquery ml versus
tensorflow that's a great question so we
I just showed you bigquery ml like you
know a little bit of sequel and you
basically have a machine learning model
it's amazing so what's all this thing
about this whole tensor flow
stuff do we need it what is it about
well the thing to realize is number one
bigquery ml is about structured data and
and in many ways if your data set is
very large and it's very sparse in other
words there's a lot of categorical
columns bigquery ml will be very
competitive with the tensor flow model
so bigquery ml would be great for large
data sets with lots of columns and
especially lots of categorical columns
that have lots of values what I'll call
a sparse data set for all other types of
data 10 through flow is a great choice
so if you have image data you have time
series data you have dense data sets you
have data sets that involve a mixture of
these things tensorflow is a much more
flexible powerful framework but the way
I like to think of bakery ml is that
bigquery ml is a great way by which
rather than writing tensorflow code to
write a machine learning model you get
to express your machine learning model
in C code so think of bigquery ml as
sequel is the user interface and in the
future
I can easily imagine a world in which
you write your model in sequel but it
doesn't get executed bigquery ml instead
it gets executed in tensorflow on cloud
ml engine but the way you express your
model could be a sequel so maybe you
want to do the separation between sequel
as a UI which is very very very
attractive and sequel as an execution
engine which may or may not be limited
in what it can do but I agree with you
Bakery ml is super cool final question
looks like our public data sets
available to be used on other cloud
providers platform also a good question
so the public data sets are public right
so many of them you can you can access
them but something like a bigquery data
set you would have to transfer the data
it's it's real I cannot imagine how you
would be able to use it from another
cloud provider
on the other hand the Google Cloud
Storage data sets you can absolutely you
can you can access it from another cloud
service provider but typically there
might be an egress fee involved because
you're actually crossing a network but
other than that yes so if there's a
public data set on Google cloud on cloud
storage and you have it you have your
code in some other cloud service
provider you should be able to access it
the way you would access any other data
on GCP so it is an open platform you
will be able to access it and you should
be able to do it so even if it isn't
bigquery and now one option might be to
basically run an extraction or no you
run a query to extract the part of the
data set that you care about and then
transfer that data over and process it
somewhere else on Prem or in some other
cloud provider
okay any other questions
all right and I guess that's a wrap
stay tuned for the next session see ETV
application observability with light
step thank you very much